i'm dana parino i'm juan williams i'm
kennedy and this is the fox news rundown
wednesday april 27 2022
i'm dave anthony many conservatives are
happy elon musk is buying twitter
hailing it is good for free speech
but it's not going over well on the left
it has just been an explosion of oh he's
racist and he's sexist and he's this and
he's that give the guy a chance he
hasn't even started yet
and lisa brady the supreme court fights
over prayer on a high school football
field if you draw their arguments to a
logical conclusion
a teacher would no longer be allowed to
bow his or her head in the cafeteria if
they wanted to offer a silent prayer
before their meal we speak with former
education secretary betsy devos
and i'm will kane and i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
it's a really big deal elon musk the
world's richest person is buying twitter
for 44 billion dollars calling the
social media company the digital town
square
and that's worrying a lot of people on
the left the president has long been
concerned about the power of large
social media platforms uh what they have
that power they have over our everyday
lives white house press secretary
jensachi the aclu says there is a danger
giving so much power to one individual
the president of the naacp is warning
about allowing hate speech and
misinformation on twitter urging musk
not to let donald trump back on the
former president was banned after last
year's capitol riot he says he's now
focused on his own truth social
messaging platform some on the left say
they're now done with twitter logging
off they're going crazy over an electric
car maker who supports free speech that
shows you how ridiculous they are
republican congressman jim jordan tells
fox the left doesn't want you to speak
if you don't agree with them you're not
allowed to talk and if you try they're
going to attack you they're going to try
to cancel you that all changes today
musk's twitter acquisition came as a
surprise to some a lot of journalistic
naysayers were saying you know musk is
just doing this for his ego he just
wants the global attention he's not
going to follow through howie kurtz
hosts media buzz on the fox news channel
and the media buzz meter podcast this is
a guy who has made a career out of
confounding the skeptics and i thought
he had a pretty good shot if he could
raise the money i mean even for elon
musk 44 billion dollars is a whole hell
of a lot of cash uh but he lined it up
there with no other uh bidders and the
twitter board didn't really have any
choice in my view but to make the best
deal for the shareholders and now the
media world is freaking out over what
this means with elon musk planning at
least to take twitter uh private and no
surprise that it's uh both sides have
very different viewpoints of it
republicans are talking about how this
is going to be great for free speech
let's go down that road first i mean
they have claimed for a long time that
twitter has been silencing conservative
viewpoints over and over and over again
for years well exhibit a the continuing
donald trump ban trump now says he
doesn't want to come back to twitter i
have no doubt that musk would allow him
to do so and i think the former
president might change his mind exhibit
b would be the squelching and then jack
dorsey the former the co-founder
admitted this is a mistake the
squelching in the end of the 2020
campaign of the hunter biden laptop
story right which was not allowed to be
shared but now of course everybody in
the media talks about it because it's
it's been confirmed so i think the
people on the right have a legitimate
point at the same time elon musk is not
a classic conservative he's kind of a
libertarian he believes in letting more
voices
thrive in a place like what he calls the
digital public square which of course is
twitter i think some conservatives may
be disappointed with him down the road i
think some liberals that are now beating
up on him may
change their tune to some extent
remember they loved him when he was
building electric cars because that's
good for the environment pollution and
all of that so he's
brilliant mercurial
erratic impulsive and a great story for
journalists
this story is going to go on and on and
on but one of the things conservatives
really want is somehow
they think that we're going to find out
the algorithms or whatever is used by
twitter to silence
their side of the story on a lot of
issues so
that's really not going to happen he's
going to take the company private right
we're not going to go under the hood of
twitter well musk has said that he would
like to make these uh that secret sauce
the algorithms public you really think
he would do that though i don't know i
never know from one day to the next what
elon musk is going to do just when i
think he's this high-minded free speech
crusader and i basically believe that he
is although i think he's going to find
in practice dealing with this
treacherous area of content moderation
is he going to want hate speech is he
going to allow threats is he going to
allow misinformation how do you define
misinformation it's it's plagued
facebook instagram tick tock and all the
other social media apps but you know one
day he is issuing these high-minded
manifestos the nexus posting uh against
a rival bill gates a pregnant man emoji
so he uh doesn't oh you know he is one
of the people his critics say you know
who uh
tries to squelch his employees with
non-disclosure agreements who sometimes
pokes a little too hard at some of his
detractors on twitter uh and so he's not
a perfect guy i don't think he claims to
be a perfect guy well but he has a
different approach well he does and and
as you talk about there are a lot of
stories and a lot of them are out there
today and they came out after the deal
about how he has had
these attempts at even getting reporters
and journalists to sign off on
non-disclosure agreements or to
give him or his company a chance to look
at stories before they're printed i mean
and he's also in other stories gone
after whistleblowers at his companies
and tried to ruin them according to
these allegations so this is not as you
said necessarily a free speech
absolutist if he's doing that for his
own company's protection right or no
right i mean look he's a hard-nosed
businessman you don't get to be the
world's richest guy without playing
hardball and i'm not defending some of
that stuff particularly you know telling
reporters they can't publish their
stories unless musk approves them that's
not journalism no self-respecting
journalist should go along with that uh
and i don't know how much hands-on
involvement he's gonna have he still has
got tesla and spacex and this boring
company to run but i think maybe you
could make a case you know his critics i
mean it's just been
it started when he first you know
became the largest single shareholder
and now since he has the twitter board
has agreed to this purchase it has just
been an explosion of oh he's racist and
he's sexist and he's this and he's that
give the guy a chance he hasn't even
started yet um but we'll see how he
deals with the question of do you allow
people to have quote free speech if they
are squelching other people's free
speech through bullying threats
intimidation hate speech and then this
question of misinformation yeah it has
been a problem for a lot of social media
companies i don't think it's going to be
that easy for even elon musk to solve it
is so hard in this era both sides claim
to have the facts right and both sides
will claim that what the other is saying
is misinformation so how who can be the
arbiter of that well i don't think uh
musk believes that there should be a
single arbiter you know but by the way
people are saying oh my god a
billionaire is going to be in charge of
this very important uh outlet the
world's richest man howie yes but jeff
bezos is also up there among the world's
richest people and he bought the
washington post so if the billionaire
happens to have views you agree with you
say it's great if the billionaire
happens to be you think uh leaning more
toward the right or libertarian side
then depending on which tribe you're
part of you either think it's great or
you think it's the worst thing ever to
befall civilization i say we wait and
see what the performance is like and by
the way a lot of the people that are
criticizing all these terrible horrible
things that must they think must will do
and maybe they'll be right we'll see
they all acknowledge that twitter is
something of a toxic place now all the
all the things about you know as i said
earlier bullying and hate speech and so
forth and the attacks on women and
anybody in the public eye including
journalists that's all going on now so
it's not like it's this pristine
paradise that suddenly is going to be
polluted uh by the world's richest man
he is in congress someday going to have
to face pressure from both sides there
are people on the right who still want
to deal with this so-called section 230
which gives companies in social media
especially a chance to get immunity from
something that somebody else has posted
on the platform and may have been
removed do you think that that is
something that is going to be weakened
over time that section or not
i might have thought so before musk i
think republicans would be more inclined
to give him a chance to quote reform
twitter as they see it uh will also
depend on whether or not trump comes
back trump has said he doesn't want to
go back to twitter but a lot of people
think eventually he will uh but also uh
you know the tech companies give a lot
of money to members of congress so it
may not be that easy to do and who knows
what the effects would be if you if if
twitter or or facebook or any of these
uh
tech giants could be sued for what
third parties meaning people their users
say on their platforms that opens up a
can of worms as well when it comes to
pushback from the left senator elizabeth
warren may lead that the democrat calls
musk's twitter purchase dangerous for
democracy when
a billionaire amasses this much power
he plays by a different set of rules
than everyone else i think the question
is what are the legal tools available
and right now tech is a largely
unregulated field warren and musk have
sparred before he once called her
senator karen tweeting she reminds him
of a friend's angry mom yelling at
everyone for no reason this is the
problem and by the way elizabeth warren
has also called for the breaking up of
facebook so she is one of the big
critics of silicon valley um when you
talk about holding people accountable uh
then you get into this sort of
existential debate about how do you do
that who is going to be the grand pub to
meet out the accountability i mean
there's so many billions of tweets and
the same thing with facebook posts etc
that no
no matter how much you spend no company
can keep up with it all so you have the
elon musk philosophy that basically good
speech will overwhelm bad speech and you
let people have their say rather than
banning them shadow banning them and so
forth and then you have the other view
which many journalists who i always
thought were more toward the free speech
uh
champion side of the scale saying no no
we have to have content moderation we
got to kick a lot of people off twitter
we can't allow this and a lot of folks
think that that's censorship that what
they really don't want is views that
disagree with their own elon musk to his
credit has said my worst critics should
remain on twitter because that's what
free speech is about uh i for one will
hold them to that but how much harder
has it been for journalism in this
social media age a lot of people get
their news off of their news feed on
facebook or or their twitter who they
follow on twitter look twitter is in one
way a tremendous
advance in communications around the
world not because it has the biggest
platform and facebook is far bigger but
because it has become kind of a global
news service journalists feel like they
have to be on it along with techies and
politicians and so it punches above its
weight it may not be the biggest tech
platform there but it has a huge
influence on news coverage uh indeed
things that might otherwise be sort of
minor feuds on twitter get blown up and
often make it onto the air or onto the
other parts of the web um and so twitter
is important who controls it is
important the fact that it's probably
going private is important and elon musk
not a boy scout by any means and i don't
think he would claim that he's had his
problems with the fcc over uh tweets
that he should not have posted um but
we're gonna see a very different
philosophy when this deal finally closes
last question what does twitter's
purchase by elon musk mean for facebook
or any of these other social media type
companies
that's an intriguing question uh mark
zuckerberg has his own problems
not least of which has to do with this
whole question of content moderation and
it's always changing you can say this
you can't say that but later you can say
it because the mainstream opinion moves
i think twitter with musk's innovations
we haven't even talked about the
technological changes that he hopes to
bring to it um the current management
has not done a great job it's why it's
never made much money
could turn twitter into certainly much
more of a competitor for some of the
other social media giants uh on the
other hand if he's a flop if people
get off if many liberals don't want to
be part of twitter anymore that could
help his rivals so it's a story that
we'll all have to continue to cover
howie kurtz host of media buzz on the
fox news channel and the media buzz
meter podcast thanks very much for
joining us thanks very much
[Music]
this is will kane with your fox news
commentary coming up
this week is seven years in the making
for joseph kennedy who was fired as an
assistant high school football coach in
2015 in a fight over free speech
religious liberty separation of church
and state he used to kneel on the
50-yard line in prayer after games and
says he never told his players from
bremerton high in washington state to
pray with him though many did raising
concern they may have felt compelled to
join in to be in the coaches good graces
when the school district
said hey
we can eliminate all of this
the what ifs if i only just stop praying
with the kids and that's exactly what i
did i never prayed with another one of
my students again after the school
district told me not to but kennedy was
still suspended and fired in part after
students from an opposing team joined
one of his solo prayers on the field he
spoke to fox's martha mccallum after
monday's arguments at the u.s supreme
court where coercion was one of the
issues raised by justice elena kagan the
idea of why the school can discipline
him
is that that puts a kind of undue
pressure a kind of coercion on students
to participate in religious activities
when they may not wish to but there were
also questions about whether kennedy had
a duty to tell students not to
participate justice neil gorsuch
highlighting a school policy that
prohibits either encouraging or
discouraging private student prayer
jeremy dice is with the non-profit law
firm first liberty institute
representing kennedy people of faith
have the right to be teachers at our
public schools they've got the right to
be coaches on our football fields as the
court said back in 1969 it can hardly be
argued that either students or teachers
must shed their constitutional rights
and walk through the schoolhouse gates
dice is hoping the justices decide too
many people are having to choose between
their faith and their job and that
kennedy's prayers are protected speech
well i think coach kennedy has a very
good chance of the court deciding in
favor of his ability to express his
faith as he saw fit former education
secretary betsy devos is part of an
amicus brief filed in support of kennedy
it's really unbelievable that the case
has had to go all the way to the supreme
court the amicus brief
really picks apart the ninth circuit
court's ruling in this case arguing in
part that the facts were revised and
then misinterpreted and not in line
with supreme court precedent
what did they get wrong with the facts
well i think the ninth circuit if you
and and i'm no lawyer but if you draw
their arguments to a logical conclusion
a teacher would no longer be allowed to
uh bow his or her head in the cafeteria
if they wanted to offer a silent prayer
before their meal
in the presence you know of other
teachers and and students and you know
this this assault on the first amendment
this is just another really i would say
egregious example of that and i think
that
coach kennedy will ultimately prevail
and the reassertion of
the opportunity individuals have to
express their faith
is is a really important one to reassert
how much
of things like that like someone you
know bowing their heads silently at
lunchtime in the cafeteria for example
or prayer before and after high school
games in general which seems like it
could be a relatively common thing i
mean how much of this already goes on in
in schools how much leeway is there
with the establishment clause right now
well it's become increasingly difficult
in more and more places um we've seen
more and more individuals have you know
their expressions their personal
expressions of their faith either
questioned or
you know they've been forced in some
cases to
stop them and i i think that this is an
important moment this case is an
important one again
to really
reassert and re-examine what the first
amendment
says and it's it's freedom of religion
not freedom from religion and yet many
of our you know cultural
pressures have been around trying on the
part of some to eradicate other people's
ability to express their faith
what about parents though who want their
kids to not
have a risk of any exposure to religion
in public schools well i i mean i think
that's that's a flawed approach um
someone's beliefs are always going to be
taught and shared
and whether it's a secular religion or a
more commonly known and understood
religious faith
somehow
beliefs are getting transmitted and you
know more broadly the idea that we
should be able to talk about ideas
disagree on different things but not to
try to you know keep anyone from being
exposed to anything i don't that's not
the issue here the coach as i understand
it and as was relayed to me
he would do this routinely after
football games and others were welcome
to join him but nobody was compelled to
join him
and for those who might be offended by
seeing someone kneeling on the field
praying all they need to do is look
somewhere else i mean it's not really an
infringement on their
turf or their rights
there is this underlying issue and it
came up during the supreme court
arguments too
the issue of whether students
inherently feel pressure to join in to
curry favor with the coach even if he
doesn't want them to join in or isn't
you know
pressuring them to join in
um that seems like a tough issue to get
around i mean you you know you want to
make the coach happy
if you think that going and joining a
prayer whether it makes you
uncomfortable or not is is going to help
you do that then there's you know what
about that argument of of the pressure
um even if he's not
you know exerting that pressure on the
students
well i think that uh those are all
obviously
issues that the justices were trying to
test and get at
but i think the the the question is how
much do students believe a teacher a
coach or whomever versus you know where
does where does trust and uh
understanding come into a situation like
this and again i just circle back around
to the the notion that this case is a
real important
uh test again of
the first amendment rights that were you
know written
into our constitution by
the founders of our country with great
intention
and we've seen first amendment rights
getting assailed across the board
be they on higher end campuses where
individuals come and you know share some
perspective on something that is
in opposition to
students on campus
and and then getting shouted down or
you know in some cases forcibly removed
from campus so this notion that
we're somehow going to
put
exterior boundaries around how an
individual can
express um their faith and or speak
freely about an issue
this this has been a an erosion over the
last number of years in our ability to
do that and i think this this case is an
important one
to come back around to and i am i i'm
very hopeful and optimistic that the
court will will find in favor of uh of
the coach in his
desire to be able to express the fate
his faith as he sees fit and i hope that
the court will strongly affirm that
do you consider this case to be part of
a
broader groundswell
of concern about what should or
shouldn't be
allowed in school well i think that
certainly this is one issue that has uh
has arisen to the level of the supreme
court
but the the reality is that teachers in
public schools should not be held
hostage to the union's hostility toward
religion
and they have regularly
tested this and this is yet another
area of testing but the
the idea that the separation of church
and state is
some sort of an invitation for the
government to forcefully separate people
from their faith is really an appalling
one and one about which everyone should
have grave concern
florida as you know has gotten a lot of
attention over its
new restrictions on discussions about
sexual orientation gender identity and
younger grades
are you surprised at how that
controversy has been playing out do you
expect more states to take similar steps
i expect that states will
do what they feel is appropriate to
ensure that kids can learn that that
when kids go to school it's it's for
learning the things that they're there
to do that you know that issue is one
that i think has
really refocused people on
what you know what is school and what is
education for and uh kids in
kindergarten and through third grade
they need to be able to be kids and get
back to being kids and not be some kind
of pawn
in a social experiment
that uh you know
again i think this is
you know the the ways the way in which
that law has been characterized i think
is
very deceptive
and the notion of of kids in
kindergarten to third grade learning
other things then
how to learn how to read and how to
write and how to start doing math
that's that's what kids should be able
to be focused on
and i i think that's the point lots of
parents are at and lots of uh
lots of political leaders who who are
willing to stand up to this
continued move toward social engineering
on the part of the system
just one more thing what would you say
to anyone who's
concerned about acceptance and
inclusivity and is worried that
restrictions and that these kinds of
debates are kind of
creating a tug of war that could lead to
hurtful situations or even
discrimination for some children well i
don't think anyone can make that
argument for kids in kindergarten
through third grade i mean i have
grandchildren those ages and kids just
want to be kids
they don't want or need the kind of
conversation and discussion that
the left would have try to forced upon
them and those grades and again
we should be we should be focused on
ensuring kids are actually learning uh
we've we've been doing an actually
pretty dismal job of that as a country
um all we need to do is look at how
we're doing vis-a-vis the rest of the
world
and um i think lots of people
can and should conclude that we've got
to get back to
helping our kids learn the things they
need to know to be able to be successful
adults
and that starts in it with a solid
foundation of learning in kindergarten
and those early years
betsy devos former u.s education
secretary thank you so much for your
time thank you lisa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
from the fox news podcast network stay
on top of the latest news and
information from fox news listen and
download the fox news hourly update on
your time the trending stories you need
anytime you want it listen and download
now by going to foxnewspodcasts.com
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
it's time for your fox news commentary
will kane
what's on your mind today is a day to
celebrate free speech but as david sacks
said on the will kane podcast this is
the fall of the berlin wall this is not
the fall of the soviet union elon musk's
purchase of twitter is a victory
for free speech but musk has one hell of
a job in front of him he has to root out
a culture of censorship within twitter
it is a culture that exists as much at
the cubicle level as it does at the
executive level little twitter employees
obsessed with mental health and toxicity
are the ones that hover over the button
of censorship and musk has to root out
that cancer what more the twitter user
base is one of the most radically left
populations in the united states of
america much of twitter's customers are
begging its employees to silence their
opposition
on top of that here comes nancy pelosi
watch as democratic politicians now
openly and aggressively begin to push
to regulate speech on the internet
fellow billionaires will apply pressure
to musk as well as will advertisers
corporate ceos finance titans and
regulators all of this will weigh
heavily on elon musk and his defense of
free speech but there is one difference
between musk and every other corporate
ceo we are suffering from a pandemic of
spinelessness
of weakness
there are many who say they believe in
free speech but bend the knee to the mob
musk
is
strong we're lucky enough that the one
billionaire who believes in free speech
is the one billionaire who has a spine
this is will kane host of the will kane
podcast which you can find by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
i'm guy benson join me weekdays at 3 p.m
eastern as we break down the biggest
stories of the day with some of the
biggest newsmakers and guests listen
live on the fox news app or get the free
podcast at guybensonshow.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes